[Music]
our daughter is a twat tired of not
being able to keep your child under
control this is where the morning-after
pills for you know will fear not for we
have the perfect solution
try 80s movies the 80s were a time when
all children's media wanted to do was
scare the out of you and now you
can bring their horrendous Horrors to
your home
hey honey want to see cute little
mousies in the secret of man thank you
kids upset wait till she sees a
decapitated woman chasing a little girl
and return to odd from little monsters
to the witches to Something Wicked This
Way Comes a teaspoons try to scare life
lessons into your child's nightmares to
the point where they can't even remember
what those life lessons are
but can't we get in trouble for showing
our kids that no problem most 80s films
have a PG rating but that was back when
it actually stood for something nowadays
it stands for practically cheap so you
can plead naive innocence to your
cruelty and lose despair sadness
eighties no was she ever socialize again
no she does just shoulder watership down
Thanks what made me a stronger human
being was guard my kids for life it
burns
Hades movies making modern media look
like pussies for generations
[Music]
oh man
hello I'm gonna stop guy remember it so
you don't have to we see a lot of stars
in our lifetime some old some new some
shine brighter than others you know that
eventually every star has to disappear
but when one that shines so uniquely
fades this guy doesn't feel the same
without it especially when it orbited a
solar system of other uniquely shining
stars that brought us a galaxy of wonder
that we still look in on today and just
in time for its 30th anniversary we're
gonna look at that galaxy
this is labyrinth
[Music]
this is a film that certainly been no
stranger in the past yet labyrinth has
never been given a full nostalgia critic
review on the one hand you can see why
it's a good movie directed by Jim Henson
written by Terry Jones produced by
George Lucas and with songs by the
film's antagonist the late David Bowie
but on the other hand it's such a
strange and out there like that it's
impossible not to shake your head and
laugh at the surreal drug overdose that
you're experiencing it deserves to be
talked about and that's exactly what
we're gonna do so experience the Wonder
and hum of one of the strangest films to
ever come out of the 80s let's take a
look at laborat Wow the owl's of
Ga'Hoole doesn't hold up as well as I
thought actually that's just the opening
credits
leading us to a girl named Sarah played
by Jennifer Connelly doing Shakespeare
in the park all by herself while
reciting lines to a perched owl and her
dog that's just what I imagined a girl
who looks like Jennifer Connelly would
do I don't believe it because every 80s
kids film has to start with the main
character being late for something she
finds she's late for babysitting her
brother Tobey and her mother's shoulder
pads are not happy about this at all
yeah as you probably notice very quickly
our main character is a bit of a pain in
the ass there was a beautiful young girl
whose stepmother always made her stay
home with the baby
she's like a one-person Facebook
argument she even gets upset if her
teddy bear is not in the right place
laughs a lot someone has been in my room
again I hate that the first sign of
accepting my white privilege is acting
like I hate it I hate you I hate you
future Oscar winner everybody couldn't
you just predict it you really wanted to
talk to me didn't you practically broke
down the door granted her performance
does give better as the film goes on but
for the first ten minutes you can pretty
much call her hayden connolly nothing to
talk about you brought him here to kill
me
take me away from this awful place
though to be fair she does go in it out
of a British accent like Carrie Fisher
you really wanted to talk to me knock it
off I wish the goblins would come and
take you maybe Lucas productions have a
weird British accent virus there are so
many medication she would be on today
you know what you need honey magic and
mystery nose Olaf and Ritalin just mix
it in with the liquid tranquilizer
it's my lullaby not working no I mustn't
I'm not saying so she offers up her baby
brother to the Goblin King again as most
teenagers do but supporters from much
from pralli intercept the message and
somehow make everything she was talking
about come true Hogwarts Paulette be
nice
[Music]
and there he is in all his bonus look at
that hair by god it's like a Tribble ate
a watermelon that died on top of Tilda
Swinton's head Sparkle goddamn Sparkle
you're the goblin king I want my brother
back forget about the baby
I can't it I don't appreciate what
you're trying to do for me I'm very
thankful you're kidnapping my brother
and sexually awakening me but I just
can't
I've brought you I don't think I like
this new version of Mary Poppins he's
there and my castle do still want to
look for him
is that the castle beyond the Goblin
City no that's a painting that's a model
and that's a very poor blue screen
effect but what do you care I'm David
Bowie you have 13 hours in which to
solve the labyrinth before your baby
brother becomes one of us so Sarah is
something of the whole goblins being
real and one of them looking like a male
gorilla de Ville and she begins her
journey through the mysterious and
whimsical labyrinth a world of magic as
you can see don't excuse me this
creatures name is hoggle who spends most
of his time finding beautiful fairies
and gasps god I loved eighties films
stir me what did you expect fairies to
do like granting wishes shows what you
know don't it I try to say I don't
believe in them but then the gay pride
parade comes around and suddenly they
all come back to life
thanks for nothing hug or its Christ do
you want to get sued well that's going
on the Goblin King partakes in what I
can only describe as a muppet show
musical number starring David Bowie
[Music]
the song is obviously the catchiest in
the film and the puffle work is great
too though let's be honest the greatest
puppet work is what's going on in David
Bowie's pants the jokes made from us
about the ferret he was so kind enough
to give a home between his legs are too
many to count in my opinion I have
already worked overtime for it so
because of this I am refusing to do my
top 10 David Bowie dick jokes for this
review it has to be top 15 I've seen
less nothing in a Thanksgiving turkey
is that got those nose and your pants
are you just happy to see me someone's
got a rocket in their pocket if you have
an erection that lasts more than four
hours but you probably David Bowie you
should have seen the nc-17 cats ground
control to Major Tom get off the blue
pill nature top the ground control tell
my wife I love her very much
Major Tom to ground control I think my
spaceship knows which way to go it's the
missing Muppet stiffy you think that was
puppeted by Frank Oz I'm doing up for
the prestige want to see my Tesla coil
you like hot dogs don't you Special
Delivery careful big package penny
tighter and those pants will be a thong
and the number one David Bowie dick Jeff
is don't touch it it's a boa constrictor
why me of all
[Applause]
Sara comes across the old riddle of one
path that leads onward and another that
leads to certain death with one gar who
always tells the truth and one who
always lies one of us always does the
truth and one of us always lies then
wood in the guy who just taught to be
telling the truth he can't live at one
of them always lies and one of them
always tells the truth because if he did
he'd be telling the truth I just ruined
this scene for you tune in next time
when I show you how Star Wars is
actually about pedophilia she thinks she
figured out the riddle but she should
have tried door number two however she
gets saved by some literal helping hands
come on which way which way oh ok happy
you hands alright but the other half
have a serious lawsuit coming oh come on
we just got over the one from Sigourney
Weaver she runs into Huggle again who
says he can help her get out of the cave
the Hidden Temple that's just he always
says that but one stone seems
particularly sparkly what have we here
for Bowie there was a weird thing to say
Salah that technically causes a song
residuals if I thought for one second
that you were betraying me I'd be forced
to suspend you headfirst in the bog of
eternal stench huh you just had one
phallic device closer to another phallic
device yeah alright I have a final
cabinet full of these the glowing orb in
his hand is nothing compared to the one
in his pants just remember there's an
entire internet full of dick jokes for
you I will never run out
he sends a giant can opener after them
but they of course is Gav and come
across what a shock something weird
okay okay all in favor of fast
forwarding is quite thank ya Sara comes
across some sort of creature being
tortured by little goblins though she
feels she shouldn't get involved in
Muppet politics she still decides to say
that's right I'm Sarah no this is the
balrog slower cousin hair clog well
that's going out we rather pointlessly
cut back to David Bowie just still being
David Bowie so is this all we do I kind
of figure there'd be a lot more gobbling
Y&R he'll whip in Ziggy Stardust out
again this edit seems particularly
strange seeing how he just appears in
the next scene anyway but you know what
they had David Bowie they're going to
use them as much as they want wouldn't
you get this silly gives Huggle a poison
fruit to give to Sarah after making fun
of the fact that she can never find
someone as ugly as him like you don't
think a young girl could ever like a
repulsive little scab like you hey come
on we can't all look like skittles
shanks from cats you'll give her that ha
galore I'll tip you straight into the
bog of eternal stench before you can
blink if she ever kisses you I'll turn
you into a prince prince of the land of
stench really riding that stench angle I
think it's gonna be the catchphrase of
the movie la la so Sarah while wandering
through the force seems to come across
oh that's unfortunate
that's um that's unfortunate you know
there's a reason most of Henson's
effects were practical and didn't
involve blue screen because that that's
the exact reason why your chin is
dragging on and the fine thing is this
scene ties into nothing I mean literally
nothing even the song is the most
forgettable in the film you could cut it
and not a thing would be affected in the
story you know the editor must have been
like mr. Henson we have to cut the scene
but we work so hard on it
it's entirely pointless but at least we
showed we could do no you didn't I'm
waiting any minute for Tim Curry to fly
in and sing a song bill could you do it
for Kermit okay I don't do this can't
say no to me boo I can't say no to
Kermit bill I would really like this
scene to stay in the movie bill pretty
please okay for you Kermit let's all
sing the alphabet song ABCDE Cookie
Monster
but I'm practically for years
it's G
Cookie Monster isn't even a letter it's
a man it's a frickin man with a shotgun
to say III mean uh G don't ever touch me
bill sorry
those Rizzo the rats mistake Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
so Sara escaped from being weirded to
death but she kisses Hong Kong which I
guess means they're sent to the bog of
eternal stench man that goblin king
really means the fine print they come
across a fox named didymus who yeah not
a fan but he does help them get across
the bridge lovely sounds like half the
dialogue in a movie but hoggle is
reminded to give Sara the poison fruit
if you're done
damn you Gerry is it not that hard to
imagine Bowie saying no I'll be fairest
in the land the fruit doesn't kill her
but instead gives a vision of
yeah hold on I'm sure I got a ball joke
in here somewhere so it looks like the
Goblin King's plan is not really as
diabolical as confusing he gives her a
fantasy where she's at an elegant ball
in a big poufy dress and she gets to
dance with a powerful sexy man I think
that's girl porn in a nutshell if I
wasn't that on Longos porn for women
calendars the song itself is relaxing
and a soothing tune but with the visuals
it looks like what every girl sees after
taking a dream from Bill Cosby what
Sarah says no Torah symbolically
suggested pedophilia and her string
hardest Lancer safely on the ground
Bowie to quote Tony Stark not great plan
chants up in the dump of broken plot
threads where yonas grandma tries to
lead her in the right direction it was
just a dream I dreamed it on that's odd
yeah you really got me there movie with
no resolution no third act in a half
hour of running time lip I'm sure this
was all just a dream Sarah says no to
her representations of teenage
consumerism meets her friends back up on
MacGuffin rock'n reaches the entrance to
the Goblin City oh the guy who handles
abusive reports on Twitter I like to
report a threat of my life they do
manage to get in but they then come
across another threat
very slow clumsy not very threatening
practice but hoggle comes in to save the
day which I guess excuses the whole
poison fruit trying to kill you thing
cherith made me give you that peach I
told you was a coward I forgive you you
do you didn't mind that I poison you hey
you got me a dance with David Bowie
we're square they go inside and come
across even more phallic imagery but
Jarrod is tired of being patient and
definitely not tired of the phallic
imagery so he does what he should have
done pretty much from the very beginning
send out a bunch of guards after her but
it's okay because Hodor is pubic hair
growls which summons a bunch of rocks
after them not since the Ewoks destroyed
the Empire has an army been so
embarrassingly taken down curse I forgot
they had rocks so they get inside the
castle but Sara insists that she needs
to go in alone I've to face him alone
but why yes because that's the way it's
done
if that is the way it is done then that
is the way you must do it onward to your
cliche remember us in the nonsensical
reunion at the end so Sarah plays
Where's Waldo MC escher addition as
Bowie proves what we've known all along
that he's actually a hologram
I knew it no man that awsome could exist
the funny thing is even though he sings
a cool song and partakes in some really
pretty damn amazing effects he looks sad
throughout the majority of it but such a
shaky motivation he becomes so subtly
emotional I'm just upset that I won't be
able to meet every girl I give a sexual
awakening to don't worry ladies I will
visit you all in your dreams not even
joking I can really do that give me the
child I can't be cruel but alas it's
time to finally hear his evil plan just
fear me love me do as I say and I will
be your slave that makes no sense
how can she submit to you and yet you be
her slave unless this is a fifty Shades
of Grey kind of thing wish to be fair if
there's any man who could pull that off
you have no power no a budget ran out so
we couldn't film a climax oh so she
recites the words from her book and
everything goes back to normal
Tobey is back the parents returned home
and somehow all her magical friends are
in a room to celebrate by singing the
villain songs
[Applause]
or at least that would be a nice ending
if we didn't know what was actually
going on this entire time that our home
did you have a good dear God honey she's
got in the papers again big dad
well okay it doesn't make as much sense
as Sarah reading a book that comes to
life because she doesn't want to babysit
her brother resulting in her fantasizing
about David Bowie Space Oddity and
reciting the words from the book makes
it all go away actually it does a lot
well the story doesn't always make sense
and it does have trouble staying focused
labyrinth is an obvious excuse just to
play with amazing visuals and cool ideas
however on top of that there really is a
lot of charm to it the characters are
simple but likable the imagination is
beyond inspiring and of course David
Boies steals the show in every frame ism
he just embodies the mystery strangeness
and all-around coolness of who he was in
this performance it's great to see so
much effort from so many talented people
come together to give us something not
perfect but passionate and full of
wonder sure can be weird and awkward at
times but stick Knology is spectacular
it's simple storytelling endearing and
its ability to suck us into another
world whether through bizarre visuals or
bizarre performances it's friggin
awesome check it out and get your magic
danceOn once more I'm the Nostalgia
Critic and wild is the wind baby
[Music]
[Applause]
you
Shalala